let's get started thank you everybody
for getting up early coming out and it's
bed but I've got some really cool stuff
to show you today about irelia I've got
some brand-new stuff that hasn't been
publicly shown off yet until until today
so thanks for getting out here
first off Who am I who here has used
irelia okay a few of you so if you've
used a relly you've probably seen me my
name is Ashley grant i'm Aurelia's
community lead also I love cars and I'm
a pilot
and if someone could please explain to
me this whole thing with like I thought
what I call french fries are called
chips here but the other night at the
restaurant they called them french fries
and I'm completely confused now so the
back and talked someone that's from
Britain could explain this to me I would
love it thank you so today we're going
to talk about first off what is irelia
I'm going to show you a demo give you an
idea of how to work with irelia how easy
it is to use irelia then i've got the
new stuff there a little bit of a
surprise for you I'm going to talk about
the current status of the framework and
show you where we're moving as a
framework so first off what is irelia
the most important thing to understand
about irelia is that it is just
JavaScript okay we write our own source
code in standard es2015 JavaScript if
you go look at the source code you'll
see that there are types in it it's not
typescript those are just flow types
that help us generate our DTS files for
those of you who are using typescript
but the great thing is we don't force
you to choose a language which with
irelia if you want to use typescript you
can use it if you want to use es2015 you
can use it if you want to use es 2015
plus new features that are coming down
the pipe I like to call that yes next
you're able to use that we built
irelia as a collection of collaborating
libraries which means that the framework
code is not monolithic we have a bunch
of repos on github that come together to
form the framework the nice thing about
this is that you can
parts of the framework and utilize them
in your own say if you were writing a
node.js application and you needed
dependency injection for that
application you can take our dependency
injection provider and utilize it in
your own code but the cooler thing about
us building the app building the
framework as a set of libraries is that
you can swap these libraries out okay
say you currently have an angular one or
a knock out application with tons of
views and you would like to translate
that application into irelia but you you
want to concentrate on rewriting your
JavaScript and not on rewriting your
views you can actually swap out our
templating and binding libraries and
teach irelia how to work with a knock
out view or with an angular 1 view or
even an angular 2 view it also means
that you can teach irelia new things by
plugging into it for example loading
react components you're able to do that
with a relly because of the architecture
of the framework as you might expect
with something built in just JavaScript
it's used to build JavaScript clients
single page applications is what we call
those a couple years ago that meant
applications that ran in a browser
nowadays it doesn't mean that anymore as
a JavaScript developer you can write
applications that run everywhere
in the browser on the desktop using
something like electron who's built an
electron application and been blown away
at how easy it is to get started with
that and how quick you can create a
distributable application self-updating
I love it and you can do that you can
use irelia with electron also on mobile
phone gap or Apache Cordova you can use
irelia to build mobile applications and
it's really nice because if you
architect your applications views
correctly you can actually use the same
code base and same views across all
three spaces it's really nice the thing
that makes a relia different from most
of the other competing frameworks as I
realize there are hundreds of frameworks
out there for you to choose from but the
thing that makes rlea different is that
we
focus on using standards the modern Daum
web components technology web components
are an emerging set of standards that
will allow you to build componentized
applications completely within the
browser without needing a JavaScript
library and that's awesome problem is
there's some warts on these
specifications and it really helps
smooth those over okay but the cool
thing is once we finish some work we
have going on you'll be able to export
an irelia component as a standard web
component a standard HTML custom element
and use that anywhere you want use it on
a vanilla j/s page or use it in a say a
react app or an angular 2 app you'll be
able to do that okay we also as the
slide says focus on using the modern Dom
who here has heard that the DOM is slow
and so we need to build a virtual Dom
yeah couple of you that used to be true
it isn't today modern 2015 2016 2017
browsers the Dom is really really fast
and if you know what you're doing you
can write JavaScript applications that
are very fast and you don't have to go
through a layer with the virtual DOM and
so that's what you get with irelia we
focus on making things fast for you we
have a lot of very smart people on our
team and they know what they know how to
eat every bit of performance out of the
browser so the philosophy of irelia
first off your open source where MIT
license we are free we always will be
free but more important than that is
that we focus on clean code and
conventions when I say clean code you go
look at our our source code for the
framework and it's very clean it's very
readable but more important than that is
that our conventions encourage you to
write clean code when you write an
irelia application the framework gets
out of your way and because of that
you're able to focus on your own code
you don't your own applications logic ok
you're not littering your code with a
bunch of boilerplate for the framework
so your code becomes cleaner
we use modern tooling such as NPM and
yarn and everything we build our tooling
on top of that we have a CLI now that
we're working on that utilizes all of
this and brings it together so that
you're utilizing familiar tooling as a
JavaScript developer and also we like to
focus on what we call the ility
testability maintainability
extensibility because the framework gets
out of your way and allows you to focus
on writing your own code that makes your
code that much more testable because
you're not having to mock up a bunch of
constructs from the framework because
you're not having to write a bunch of
framework code that makes your own code
more maintainable if there's less code
to maintain it's going to be more
maintainable and also the framework
itself is extremely extensible as I just
said you can teach the framework how to
parse and render a knockout JSU or an
angular 1 view okay we I have demos that
I've shown off where we teach irelia how
to render into a markdown document think
of how powerful that is that you're not
tied to just one single view a view
implementation and also we are
experiencing rapid adoption in a large
active community I can tell you I was at
NBC Sydney a couple months ago and I
gave this talk and there was a lot fewer
people in the room okay and I think
after the stuff I show off today we're
going to have even more people coming on
board okay if you go check out our git
er Channel git er dot IM slash irelia
slash discuss you'll see thousands of
people from around the world discussing
irelia getting help with irelia problems
if you go to stack overflow like me and
put and subscribe to irelia questions on
stack overflow your email inbox is going
to get blown up with people asking
because there's that many people using
irelia we often hear about the other
major players in the framework world and
you think that there isn't other options
but there are and there's tons of people
out there utilizing irelia to build
amazing application
now next we're going to get into my
demos and if you'd like to follow along
or you want to try this out when you get
home you can go and download one of our
beginner kits these are really great
because you download a zip file and then
you you unzip it and you can immediately
run this thing it will transpile all of
your code in the browser which obviously
isn't good for production but we're just
playing around this is really nice to
get started without having to go and
install NPM and know all of those
commands and everything and understand
what's going on you can just open up
this thing and start coding especially
if you have Firefox just open index.html
and then in a text editor of your choice
start editing files and keep hitting
refresh really nice but for me today I'm
going to be utilizing our irelia CLI
which is a bit of tooling that we're
working on that will make your job as a
developer very easy it's very useful I
used it in my workshop on Monday and it
doesn't matter if you're an expert
developer in the modern JavaScript space
or a complete beginner this thing this
tool will make their life easier so
let's go look at the code so first off
every irelia application that you build
will be loaded from some type of HTML
file whether that's rendered by some
type of server frameworks such as asp
net or asp net core or it's just a
completely static HTML file okay when
you generate an application using our
CLI it will give you a file that looks
like this
so out of the box you get a very I mean
there's 11 lines of code here there's
not a ton that we have to do ok but the
most important lines in here are lines 8
& 9 on line 8 we have the body tag and
it has an attribute on it called irelia
app this tells irelia where you want
your application to live on in the
browser ok if you don't give this
attribute a value irelia will use
conventions to decide where to go to
start loading your application
it'll go look for two files in the root
of your source folders called app J s
and F HTML and it will load a default
configuration of the framework and go
from there for you it'll you just able
to get up and started with zero
configuration so I must a little apart
from that boat cruise last night but
most applications are going to need some
type of custom configuration whether
you're setting up some plugins or you
want to set up say authentication
providers or something like that and
you're going to need to configure that
stuff before the framework itself get
started so to do that we give you the
option of giving a value to this irelia
app attribute you give that that value
and a rally will go look for a file with
that name in es2015 all JavaScript files
or modules so irelia will look at this
file which is a module and see if it
exports a function called configure it
will then call that function and it will
pass you everything you need to be able
to configure the framework line 9 is
where we actually load up the JavaScript
to run everything this we utilize
require j/s which I'm sure I'm hearing
some groans it's not web pack or
whatever web pack is coming but I'll
tell you what requirejs is really fast
okay um but we use requirejs in our CLI
and it just a data main says load our
bootstrapper and the bootstrapper takes
over so let's go look at some actual
irelia code this is your first
irelia view this is our templating
language here we just use dollar sign
curly brace which comes from es2015 it's
a string interpolation which is a new
feature with JavaScript es2015 we we
like to take language features from
javascript and put them into our view
language so that the amount of context
switching that you have to do as a
developer is minimal okay and you'll see
that a couple other places in this demo
so all this all that this template does
is just display the
message and as I'm sure you can guess
that message is hello world here we have
a very simple class you'll first notice
there is no irelia here okay all of the
configuration of the framework was done
in that main J's file I talked about and
there is some stuff in here
but if you look at this this is very
little going on I just tell irelia to
use the standard configuration I set up
what's called a feature okay and then I
just call start very little code you
know not a ton to do to get started with
our Elliot and so when this runs this is
what we get and I know this is
earth-shattering right everybody's
excited but think about some of the
frameworks you've used where it's
hundreds of lines of code just to write
hello world okay and with this argument
are our CLI will generate it for you and
you see that it's basically five or six
lines of code if I had not used a value
on that irelia app attribute it
literally would have been five or six
lines of code okay so next let's let's
get exciting let's let's actually build
something so I'm going to replace the
javascript in a pas with a new class
called welcome okay in here I've got a
couple of class properties I'm utilizing
an upcoming part of the JavaScript
standard called class properties to set
up three strings I have a getter that
will take the first name and last name
property and concatenate them I know
it's crazy what I'm doing here
this is high level JavaScript and
finally we have a function that when you
call it it'll pop up an alert on the
page the important thing to notice here
though is again there is no irelia the
word irelia except in that string
doesn't exist on this page okay this is
it there there is no man behind the
curtain here you see I have these four
files that's it
this resources folder that's it there's
just a configure function in there
okay I'm not hiding anything here so
let's display let's create a view here
this is our view for this you'll see on
the first line for a second line I load
bootstrap I'm able to require in CSS
resources you can also teach irelia
through various plugins to be able to
require an stuff say a markdown file if
you want to pull a markdown file into
your view for something you can teach
irelia how to do that okay next you see
the string interpolation again here to
show the heading of the page the welcome
to irelia string and then we come down
in here and we have a form element and
you'll see that we have two text boxes
here and both of them basically look the
same and they look like standard HTML
except that here instead of saying value
it says value dot bind okay this is how
Aurelia's binding engine works when
you're binding to HTML attributes okay
you will see it wherever you see a
period or a dot in a norelli of you you
can assume irelia is going to do
something in fact if you go look at our
source code you'll see that what it does
is it goes and it looks for dots and
attribute names value dot bind it gives
you the default binding direction
between your view and your view model
okay the default for most things is
going to be one-way data-binding coming
from the view model into the view but
where it makes sense by convention we
give you two way data binding okay so
here on a text box it makes sense to
have two-way data binding so that you'll
know about changes to the first name or
the last name property right so we the
framework by default gives you that but
conventions are great up until the
minute they don't work for you and when
they don't work for you you want it to
be easy to override the convention okay
or to be explicit even if you agree with
the convention you want to be explicit
and to do that in irelia is very easy
here if I want to be explicit that this
is going to be a two-way data
I just say value to - way you'll notice
that it popped up with intellisense I'm
utilizing Visual Studio codes irelia
plugin
which is really cool so two way is
explicit that this is going to be a
two-way data-binding anytime you want
you can use it okay
anybody guess if I want to force this to
be a one-way data-binding how I would do
that anybody come on one way yeah so now
this is going to be a one-way
data-binding from the view model into
the view so anything I type in this text
box isn't going to get updated into the
view model okay a lot of times that's
what you want for example if you were
data binding on to a class attribute or
something that's perfectly fine because
the users not likely to be updating that
value on a textbox though it kind of
makes sense for it to be two-way we do
though we have one other data binding
direction that you can use which is
useful for performance which is the
one-time data binding anybody guess how
one-time works I just say one - time I
hope you're starting to notice that
irelia just makes sense
okay what you expect it to be is what
it's going to be with irelia okay it's a
framework that's very easy to learn in
fact by the end of this 15-minute demo
you're going to basically know 80% of
what you need to know to build a relia
application and that's that's not BS
that is true you'll fully understand our
binding engine by the end of this ok all
of that talk though I'm just going to
accept the default of a two-way
data-binding
we come down here we have another string
interpolation you'll see that even
though this is using the getter
everything just works as you'd expect
okay and then we have a submit button
down here so when the submit button half
of it is clicked the form elements
submit event is going to get fired so
how do you bind to an event in irelia
well we have two bindings we have
trigger and delegate up here on this
form you see that I've got submit
trigger what trigger does is it
catches the event handler directly to
that HTML element okay
sometimes that's a really good thing to
do for example if you had a click event
or something and you want to make sure
you're getting the click on that one
thing and you don't want things to
bubble up but a lot of times for
performance reasons it's good to use a
delegation utilize event bubbling and
have one event handler on the page that
delegates out where things need to go
and with irelia it's as simple as
changing from trigger to delegate and
now you're using event delegation think
of when you're inside of a loop on a
with a repeater or something and you've
got say a table of values and you have
an edit button on every line you don't
want to have hundreds possibly thousands
of events being created so dot delegate
will get get you out of that problem
quite quickly so in this case I'm going
to go ahead and use delegate and what
will happen is anything here this is a
function but anything that you pass in
between the parameters will be passed to
that function when it's called that's
really nice if I can pass in hard-coded
values here or I can pass in other
values coming from somewhere else on the
page or something it is really nice to
be able to do that for example inside a
repeater when I have an edit function
just on my main view model and I want to
pass the specific item that I'm working
on I would pass that in here okay so
that's a lot of talk let's see what it
looks like this is crazy right so the
people who are using a relative should
look very familiar this is our skeleton
application the home page of our
skeleton so as I type here if I change
this to Jo it gets updated okay and use
my own last name grant and if I click
Submit the event fires so that's pretty
cool without utilizing any framework
code in my JavaScript I was able to get
an application running with the relative
and I like to ignore the main KS because
for this demo it's just not necessary
but the
see Li puts it there so I just I don't
count it okay so that's cool but as I
talked about with irelia you build
single page applications and this is
about a single page as you can get you
know we don't have any other pages in
our application this is the entire
application and it's not very exciting
alright so let's go ahead and we'll add
a wrapper around this so that we can
start doing some navigation within this
application so the first thing I'm going
to do is change this file names from app
HTML and app j/s to welcome HTML and
welcome that jas and then I'm going to
come MRE create a pas and app dot HTML
is that thing flickering
are you having a problem so it's just
the there okay
sorry guys the projectors messin up okay
so in app J s I've got another little
bit of code here what I'm doing here is
setting up a router in irelia this is
how you do it any page that needs to
have a router whether it's the main
application router or a child router all
you have to do is put a function on the
class called configure router irelia
will see it and call it okay it'll pass
you a router configuration object and
the router itself okay
so here we set up a single route which
points to that welcome module that I
just created and then we set router as a
property on our class for those who
aren't familiar with routers routers are
used for navigating around an
application and passing parameters and
stuff they also enable stuff like deep
linking into your application on this on
this HTML file I've got a bunch of
bootstrap navbar code which isn't very
interesting so I'm just going to get rid
of it for a second and look at line 33
where we have this router view custom
element this is the first custom element
that you're seeing a large part of
building irelia applications is building
on custom elements whether your own
custom elements or in this case a custom
element provided by the framework okay
the router view element tells irelia
this page is going to have a router and
a minute ago I said that whenever you
export a configure router function
irelia will see it and call it as a
slight lie because actually what happens
is when you have a router view element
in your view then irelia will go looking
for a configure router method okay you
don't have to set up like a typescript
interface and implement it or anything
you just write the configure router
method and irelia will call it for you
okay so I ignored this navbar let's go
look at it because there is some
interesting code
here you'll see that the routers title
is being interpolate it in but the more
important thing here is that we have a
repeater
okay now hourly I talked about with
string interpolation that we're bringing
es2015 features into this view ma into
the view so that you're minimizing your
context switching with our repeater we
do the same thing you see that says
repeat that for row of router navigation
the for of loop is a new feature of
es2015 that is a for loop that works
like you might expect it to on
collections so with irelia we decided we
will use that loop in our repeater so
for every item in the routers navigation
property we will get a new row what is
the routers navigation property well any
route that you set as nav true in its
configuration gets attached to this it's
a great way for building exactly what
we're building here a navigation bar
okay so for each of these items we do we
check if the route is active and if it
is we attach a class called active
otherwise we don't put any class on the
list item and then we have a link here
and we bind the routes href property to
the links href property pretty simple
right
and there's one last thing we do which
is that whenever the routers is
navigating property is true we want to
show a spinner so to do that we use
Aurelia's if custom attribute this comes
with the framework the if binding allows
you to add and remove items from the Dom
okay sometimes it makes sense to
completely remove things from the Dom
other times you just want to hide stuff
we also provide a custom attribute for
that called Show okay if to add and
remove from the Dom Show to just hide
things basically set display none on
them but here we've decided to use the
if binding so if we go back and look you
see that now we have a nice navbar
you'll also notice that the page we just
worked with is now a page in the
application it's no longer the entire
application I did not touch the code to
do this okay all I did was change the
file name and that's cool but what good
is having a router and having a navbar
if when we have one route right so let's
go ahead we'll add a second page to this
application so we can navigate back and
forth between the two pages so to do
that first
I will go to our router and I will copy
this route and then paste it below and
I'm going to call this new route welcome
there are any users so I'll say users
I'm going to point to a module called
users and I will create this module in
just a second and then here I'll get rid
of all of this just point to users okay
and then over here I'm going to create
two new files users j/s and users dot
HTML notice the convention there of a
view and a view model being paired up
and you not having to tell the framework
okay by convention we look for it but if
you need to override that you can tell
us explicitly listen I want you to use
this exact view or you can tell us
here's a function that will determine
what file to use okay you can also put
your view your template inline in the
page using a decorator called inline
view and you can put you can have single
file components with irelia but for this
demo I'm just using the convention so
first here I will add in a little bit of
code
now this is the first file in this
entire application where I'm actually
bringing things in I'm importing modules
from irelia okay I bring in something
called inject from irelia framework and
then I also bring in our fetch client if
you're familiar with fetch it is a new
type of way to do you know pull in
resources and make API calls make HTTP
calls it's supposed to replace XML HTTP
requests Ajax and then I load a polyfill
for fetch because it's fairly new and
not all browsers implement it next I use
the inject that I decorated here or that
I imported here to decorate our class
decorators are in an emerging standard
in JavaScript that will be part of the
language very soon
pretty much every modern JavaScript
framework uses it angel ur - ember us we
all use it and I use this to tell irelia
I want you to inject a dependency for me
that dependency being our fetch client
irelia utilizes constructor injection so
I write out a constructor and in the
constructor I configure this fetch
client to tell it that it's base URL is
going to be github x' api and i set that
as a property on my class then i have a
function called activate this is part of
Aurelia's router lifecycle okay when you
have a page that's being routed if the
irelia will look on the module and say
does it have an activate method does it
have these certain life cycle methods
and if they're there or le will call
them if they aren't irelia just moves on
with its day and the great thing about
router life cycle methods is that they
are promise aware you can return a
promise from one of these methods and
tell the router to hold off until you're
finished doing whatever you need
whatever work you need to do before the
page can be loaded so with activate when
irelia goes to activate a page first it
will see if you have this function it'll
call it and if if you are like in this
case returning returning a promise
because fetch is a promise of fied api
or le will wait
we can wait to load the page until our
call to github has completed okay
nothing too fancy going on here we just
ask github for a list of its users and
then we set that as a property on our
class ok over in our view we have stuff
that you've already seen before remember
I said that by the end of this demo you
will know 80% of what you need to know
to build an irelia application what's
starting to come true you've already
seen our repeater ok we're repeating
over every user okay and then we're
binding using the default binding on the
source for this image to get the the
users profile photo and then we're using
binding down here again on to create a
link to that users profile ok so if we
come back over here you'll see that now
I have a second link up here because I
created a second route and if I click on
it it just loads a list of github users
right but now we have two pages we have
a full navigable irelia application ok
and I did this with a minimum amount of
a relly a specific code okay I think
that's really cool because I like when a
framework lets me tell it what to do not
when it tells me what to do
ok the other thing I like though is
doing dumb things on stage doing things
that I would never do at a real job okay
I feel like demos need to have people do
something dumb like where you're sitting
in the audience going why are they doing
that I would never do that so I'm going
to do that what I'm going to do is show
off how in a relia every single page
that you create is also a custom element
okay so here back on this page that we
first created our Welcome dot HTML file
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
here at the bottom
add a custom element called welcome okay
I'm on a page called welcome in a module
called welcome by convention irelia says
okay if you want to use a custom element
from this module that's called welcome
the file or the custom element will call
be called welcome because I'm already
inside that page that resource is
already available to me without having
to require it in like you saw me do with
CSS before okay so I've got a recursive
page here now okay and if I were to save
this it would cause my browser to crash
in fact I'll show you so I come here and
I go to the welcome page you see that it
tried to go to welcome and it failed and
if I you probably won't be able to see
this but if I pull up the error message
here down here maximum call stack size
exceeded which is obvious I had an
infinitely recursive page right so we
don't want that so what I'm going to
need to do here is oh I need to put some
way for the user for me to say okay I
want you to add that to the Dom right
remember back to our navbar where I used
the if not bind on the spinner to add
and remove things from the Dom that's a
very useful thing for me to have right
here so what I'll do is I'll create a
checkbox that will determine if this
thing should be in the Dom or not okay
Simplot type equals checkbox and then
check dot bind
earth sorry not check that by what I'm
going to do is use ref okay ref equals
do dumb stuff
now what this ref attribute does is it
takes this HTML element and makes it a
property on your view model okay that
means it's able to be used in your
JavaScript code but it's also able to be
used in my view okay so I'm going to
take that and we'll come down here
I'm gonna say if mind equals do dumb
stuff checked okay save the file come
over here and now everything lows okay
so as I click the checkboxes the
recursive page continues to be recursive
right but the problem I have if I'm
doing dumb stuff I like to do dumb stuff
you know I want to go all out and the
problem I have is that when I type my
name here it's not going down the page
all right like let's do this right so
what I'm going to do is I want to bind
this page this page is first name
property to the custom elements first
name property all right
so to do that I would say first - name
dot bind equals first name okay
this isn't going to work yet though
because I have to tell irelia that the
first name property is bindable okay so
let's go ahead and do that I'll come
over to welcome Jas and I will import
bindable
from the framework and then that is a
decorator just like we saw with the
inject decorator being set on the class
well the bindable decorator in this case
is going to be set on this property so I
just say bindable first thing that's it
I come back over here and I set a couple
things
and now when I type my name it goes down
the page right that was pretty cool that
was really really easy wasn't it
I'm sure a couple of you though are
wondering why it says first - name
equals first name right well HTML is
case insensitive okay so in irelia we
have to have a way of translating
between javascript property names and
HTML attribute names and the way we do
that is we convert from javascript
camelcase to HTML what we call kebab
case or
- case I call it kebab case because
kebabs are delicious right but let's go
back over here and notice something
which is the data only goes down doesn't
come back up right and again I can't it
reiterate this enough I like to do
stupid things so I want the data binding
to go in both directions how do we do
that
anybody remember how I force a binding
to be two-way I just say to - way and
now this becomes the two-way
data-binding okay pretty cool right so I
took this page from being the entire
application to being a page in the
application to being a custom component
and itself that's pretty awesome right
but I have one more trick up my sleeve
so I'll go ahead and close these two
files and I'm gonna come back to app
HTML and you remember with app HTML I
said I have this whole boatload of nav
bar code and it really I don't feel like
this fits here I want to componentize my
application so I want my nav bar to be
its own component right but the thing is
there's really no behavior with this
it's all view logic that's going on it's
all specified in the view okay
so it'd be really nice if I could create
a component or a custom element without
having to go and write any JavaScript
for that well with irelia that is
possible and I'll show you how I'm going
to create a new file here called navbar
HTML and inside of it I'm going to
create a template element one thing I
failed to mention is that all irelia
views are wrapped in the template
element this is a part of the web
components spec and it's really nice
because it gives you HTML that the
browser will not parse until you tell it
to okay so we utilize that in irelia
and I'm going to come back over here I'm
going to take out all of that code and
just paste it in here and that's nice
and all but the problem I have is that I
have I have this repeater that's
repeating over a router and I have a
property called router that I'm doing
data binding to so I need to be able to
bind to that property but remember I
don't have any JavaScript code so I
can't go and import that bindable
decorator so I need a way of doing that
well what we came up with is an
attribute custom attribute on the
template element called bindable and you
can add a comma-separated list of
properties that you want to be able to
data bind to these are always going to
be one-way data bound the only way you
can override that is with our two-way
data binding but we'll come in here and
I'm going to say bindable equals router
I'll save that I come back over here now
I do need to require in this thing
require again is how you pull in
external resources external from your
view so I say NAB dash bar in this case
I'm going to put HTML the dot HTML tells
irelia this is an HTML only custom
element okay
then I just say navbar router dot bind
equals router and I've got I've got that
so I come back over here everything
looks the same but what's cool is that
if I come here and inspect I scroll up
just a little bit see that now I have a
nav bar element in there okay I've
completely removed the nav bar from my
main view and I didn't have to write any
JavaScript to do it okay so what is it
when you're able to do these things
you're able to take a page from being
the entire application to being a page
in the application to being a custom
element inside itself what is it when
you're able to create a custom element
without writing any job
script code what is it I call it magic I
just I wish I had music every time this
place okay so that's it with the demo
that's the demo you've probably already
seen for everybody watching online and
now comes the cool stuff that you
haven't seen before because it's now
time for something completely different
and I don't have the explosion like
Monty Python head but stick with me here
who here has written applications
utilizing modern JavaScript frameworks
that were not irelia maybe angular 2 or
something okay yeah lots of you have you
heard of something called hot module
reloading okay it's a really really
useful feature webpack enables it okay
and you notice I was using our CLI here
in this demo and every single time I
would save a file the page would reload
and I'd lose all of my state that can be
really frustrating when you're trying to
debug code well we heard you and we are
finally getting hot module reloading out
there so I have here our navigation app
it looks very familiar right
and it doesn't have oh yeah the first
names down here you can see I've already
been playing with it so this one here by
default everything is set as John Doe
but I'm going to change this to be
Ashley
okay and then I'm going to come over to
Visual Studio code okay and I'm going to
take this here cut it from there and
paste it up here and then I save it and
when I come back over here in just a
second this there goes it just hot
module reloading that for me okay this
is not something you can do with our CLI
today we hope to implement this soon as
soon but this is something you can play
with today if you go to our skeleton
navigation repo on github
and pull that down and then go to the
typescript experimental or webpack
experimental branch you can play with
this today okay
this is a very important feature for
lots of developers and it's something
that a lot of people said wasn't
possible with mvvm style frameworks
because we have state that's inside of
there you know we don't have a single
source of state and everything but I'm
here showing you it is possible okay and
this is going to be part of our official
release very soon probably within the
next couple of weeks this will be
officially released now the other thing
I want to show is something called
server-side rendering server-side
rendering is very important for both
initial render speed on a page and
search engine optimizations everybody
familiar with what server-side rendering
is for JavaScript frameworks yeah this
has been a failing of irelia for a long
time we did not have a server-side
rendering story and a people would
complain about this and so we listened
and we I'm here to show you for the
first time this literally didn't get
finished until last night
Buzzelli our web fat guy got this up and
running this is here this is a
server-side rendered irelia app okay and
I'm going to prove it to you because
first here this application is not using
server-side rendering and if we go and
look at the source that was shipped over
from the the server it's very short this
is a web pack version of what I showed
you before it's only 20 lines of code
but if I look at this application and
look at the source you'll see that the
entire application is being rendered
here okay so we have our first name and
last name and everything much for some
reason my scrollbar isn't working very
well you will notice that I switched
over to Anna boon to VM one of the
dependencies that we utilize to do hot
module reloading for some reason doesn't
work on Windows right now but it does
work just fine on Mac and Linux
okay but you're probably thinking this
is still fake I hand wrote this or
something well if I go over to my
terminal eventually
eventually I have there we go okay so
here I have a server running on port 87
65 and you can see where it's outputting
everything from irelia as the browser
loads up everything okay as the server
takes Aurelia's JavaScript code and
renders it it spits this out when you
run irelia just in the browser you get
the same sort of stuff this is the
development logging that was configured
on main j/s okay and so if i come back
over to chrome and i refresh the page
you'll see that it just refreshed and I
have another thing there so there's not
smoke and mirrors this is actually
irelia being rendered by nodejs okay
server-side rendering is a bit of a
funny story okay there are some
frameworks there server-side rendering
is just what I showed you here where
they spit out HTML into the browser and
then in the browser they let the
framework get started startup and then
they just swap the Dom okay and that's
nice but sometimes you get a bit of a
flash as the Dom elements get swapped
out so our goal with irelia is that our
server-side rendering in the next month
or two we're going to give you the
ability to basically hot start the
framework
aurelion will be able to look at what
the HTML and the state that the browser
created when it rendered the page
initially and hot start it will take
that and get started and it will take
over that Dom okay we also hope to like
queue up events like if a user clicks it
takes the framework you know a couple
milliseconds 50 to 100 milliseconds to
get started in that time it's possible
that a user could have already clicked a
button or click the link that the router
needs to deal with we want to queue
those up so that one of the router when
the application does get started in the
browser we're able to get moving with
that our goal is to have the best
server-side rendering story of any
modern JavaScript framework okay
and again you guys are literally the
first ones to see server-side rendering
outside of the irelia team I went on the
the cruise last night down the Thames
and when I got back
Vasily got back to me and told me he had
this running and so it was at midnight
last night that I added this to the demo
ok so I have obviously convinced
everyone because you're you're all
jumping and cheering sorry it's not a
microphone you can't hear it on the
video but anyways so you want to know
where is the framework now and where is
it going to be going right so what's the
current status of the framework we
released version 1.0 back in July of
2016 last year ok we've continued
working on it the framework is fully
featured you can use this to build real
applications okay in fact I will show
you some real applications being that
are on the internet just in just a
minute I have getting close up my time
but I have a couple of minutes our
documentation site is awesome ok I will
tell you how awesome it is Rob Eisenberg
who started irelia had the idea for how
we were going to create our
documentation and we implemented it as a
team ok you can go there it has some
really cool features like you can you it
has like Who am I or what is my role
option and you could say that you know
I'm a developer and we give you
everything about the browser gives you
technical documentation and everything
or you can say for example I'm a manager
I'm a CTO and if you choose CTO we give
you like small words and things that are
easy to understand ok and this was so
awesome that Microsoft saw it and they
hired him Rob is now working at
Microsoft on Docs Microsoft calm ok he
still works on irelia in fact the
framework is stronger than ever with Rob
at Microsoft ok I promise you don't
don't worry about Rob being at Microsoft
I'm super excited about the future as I
said real applications in development
and in production I'll show you a couple
of just a minute do we have anybody in
here that speaks Norwegian
we're Swedish awesome because that's
going to come in handy in a minute okay
we are currently working on enhancements
for our CLI we're going to be
integrating webpack and hopefully system
Jas and JSP em into the CLI so that you
utilize the great power that comes with
web pack from our CLI it'll be great for
people who don't want to learn all of
the configuration necessary to really
get the power out of web pack but they
still want that power as you just saw
server rendering we're always working on
bug fixes if you submit issues on github
we try to fix them as quickly as
possible alright thank you
but I'm not done really quickly I would
like to go to my browser and I'm going
to pull up Aurelia's blog because just
this morning we published a blog post of
a case study from the Nordic cinema
group okay and if we go here to this
yeah okay Norwegian or Swedish I think
I'm on the Swedish site okay but this is
an irelia application you can choose yes
Swedish because it's Gothenburg
okay so we'll say we're in Gothenburg
this is it's like Fandango okay you can
go and buy theatre tickets this is this
is a fear of movie company and they sell
them okay it's a beautiful beautiful
application that they're going to be
launching into production very soon okay
and you see that they have one thing to
notice here is that there there's not a
pound sign up here okay they're
utilizing a relia router the irelia
routers ability to work with modern
browsers to visit servers or something
anyways to not have to use hashes for
routes okay so that it looks just like a
standard URL okay but we can also come
over here and I want to see Milana
English its mallanna okay and you know I
can choose stuff and just to prove to
you that this is irelia I will inspect
this and you see a you target ID
somewhere up here yeah you'll see like
ref equals and stuff this is an actual
irelia application okay people are using
irelia large companies are using
aurelion not not just nordic cinema
groups okay there are tons of people out
there using using irelia um just last
week I was talking to a developer who's
working with one of the largest one of
the largest automobile manufacturers in
the world and he was telling me about
the work he had been doing at that
manufacturer with irelia okay so anyways
like to thank you guys for coming out I
welcome feedback please drop lots of
greens in the box outside okay
also if you want to give me a feedback
via text go to my Twitter it's on here
you can send me messages on Twitter okay
so thank you
[Applause]